the covet 19 pandemic will have a huge
effect on thanksgiving this year
a lot of families will not travel and
gather together
but what about the ones that will
amazon's created a brand new echo device
with alexa
built just for this year's family
gatherings
take a look uh i'm gonna need a xanax to
prepare me for what your mother's gonna
say at the dinner table
don't worry alexa's on it huh
hmm stuffing's great babe thanks you
know it's not great
this damn china virus and the lockdown's
worse than the disease hey
who's in the mood for some celebrity
trivia yes please i am
i am i am just in time for what's sure
to be a stressful family thanksgiving
it's the new amazon echo with
subject-changing alexa
did you know that ryan gosling and
sandra bullock once dated
i did not know that i'm just looking
forward to trump's second inauguration
on january 20th okay speaking of
presidents
did you know that president theodore
roosevelt had a pet hyena
hey kids who would like a pet hyena me i
knew
maybe thanks alexa mom does too
amazon echo with subject changing alexa
your most important guest this
thanksgiving